I try and know what the world is right I
mean I you think that'd be intuitive but
it's not always you know lado and not
everybody knows but I really do try and
do that i mean i think that was the
thing with 300 and i think they're know
as long as you can tell the actors you
know that's where you know that is this
is where this is if you turn like that
you're gonna be facing the ocean you
know things like that so they know
because in the end I think when they get
into the drama if there's someone else
staying that they could talk to it's
like a play anyway right this world kind
of goes away you're sort of in that
moment um so I really try and approach
it that way I say okay look usually use
your other user the person you're with
they'll ground you and as long as you're
confident that I know where you are you
can let that go you know you can put the
reality of the world around you go I'm
not gonna let you do something stupid
and I think once they get that trust to
me that's how it's kind of how I try and
do it peaked at the thing with Alan and
the thing with watchman as far as you
know keeping the sort of whatever
nonlinear aspects of the movie the
characters all driving forward and then
in the end sort of the greater metaphor
that is the lesson of the film if you
will I mean the only way to do it I mean
I keep it all square in your head I draw
and I like trying you know I I basically
you know what I did like we write to the
script and I'm constantly sort of
working on it the ideas you reach a
point of saturation where then you sort
of are able to have an intuitive
response to everything I sort of stay in
the zone of what is watchman II and what
does not watch me and that only comes
with sort of i felt like it for me it
only came you know after time living
with the material and sort of having it
become part of you you know the
technology is there for me i think the
thing that's cool about the technology
right now is that there is nothing
it really true now if you can think it
you can film it what's cool is that the
technology has not taken place of the
story I don't think you know you can't
replace a good story with technology